ahora que ya sabemos qué significa
cuando un comerciante se refiere a que
el mercado se encuentra en contango
vamos a ver si se trata de una situación
alcista o bajista para los precios en
esta materia prima en particular como
les mencioné en el vídeo anterior es
normal que existan materias primas que
estén en contacto ya que se tome en
cuenta el costo de oportunidad del
efectivo y el costo de almacenamiento
para esa materia prima si algo tiene un
contango razonable no podemos decir
realmente si estamos en una
circunstancia alcista o bajista es
simplemente algo que se espera que
ocurra lo que no es algo usual es tener
un contango severo contango severo y
esto es cuando el precio actual es mucho
pero mucho menor en comparación al
precio futuro de esa materia prima y en
esa situación como mencionamos en el
vídeo anterior podemos percibir que
existe una gran cantidad de esa materia
prima ahora en el mercado o que quizás
se percibe que va a haber una escasez de
este producto en el futuro
esto se percibe aunque no podemos decir
o determinar algunas circunstancias
simplemente con una sola señal pero la
idea general es que un contango severo
es una señal bajista señal bajista con
respecto al precio futuro de esa materia
prima y la razón por la que se percibe
como bajista es porque si tenemos esta
discrepancia tan grande todo lo que
alguien tiene que hacer es comprar mucho
petróleo el día de hoy asumiendo que
esos son los precios del petróleo es
comprar mucho petróleo el día de hoy que
es barato almacenarlo y de nuevo estamos
asumiendo que este es un contango severo
por lo que no nos va a costar 100
dólares por barril su almacenamiento y
después vamos a acordar venderlo por 150
dólares dentro de un año por lo que
acordamos venderlo asumiendo que el
costo de almacenamiento es menor que 100
dólares
de esta manera garantizaremos recibir
cierto dinero si tenemos a muchas
personas haciendo esto comprando en el
mercado actual van a aumentar la demanda
en este mercado de este producto y va a
aumentar el precio del mismo y para el
mercado futuro tenemos a muchas personas
que han acordado vender en el futuro por
lo que va a disminuir el precio de este
producto en el futuro por lo que en
general un contango severo es una
situación bajista para el precio futuro